welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled extraction-free
sensitive detection of viral rna using
direct rt pcr chemistry it's my pleasure
to introduce you to donald green
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box our presenter will
address your questions following at the
end of the presentation
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
please join me in welcoming donald green
i will now turn the presentation over to
him
hello everyone
hello and welcome to lab week thank you
lab roots for giving sativa the
opportunity to present my name is donald
green i am a field application
specialist for saitiva and today i will
be discussing
our new direct rtq pcr kit the kit can
be broken into two parts the aic mix
which is the part that makes it
extraction free
and the rtq pcr chemistry which is also
lyell stable
i'll get into more of that later on in
the discussion
but please i hope you enjoy the content
and i look forward to you reaching out
with questions
before we jump head first into the kit i
will discuss a few other topics the
first one the pcr and rtpcr market
polymerase chain reaction or pcr is one
of the major advances in the field of
molecular biology used in diagnostic and
research laboratories the world over to
generate really sufficient quantities of
dna to be tested the global reach of
digital pcr and qpcr
has been expected to grow by leaps and
bounds
the increase is really due to the
availability and higher demand for
different kinds of master mixes for the
technology government funding
to the diagnostic and life science
sector and really an evolution of pcr
variants that have led to an increased
application
in the diagnosis of infectious diseases
the next question would be why reverse
transcription quantitative pcr or rtq
pcr
we use rtqpcr to amplify a transcribed
cdna from rna into multiple copies it's
quantitative which means it measures dna
concentration in real time and it
typically has a one-step process or
two-step process in the one-step process
we use it for large samples to really
reduce chances of the contamination
process
in the process the two-step process is
preferred when sample is scarce or
multiple sampling may be required from
one sample
so if we take a look at where rtq pcr is
widely used
we can see that it's been widely used to
calculate rna expression levels within
tissue diagnose genetic disorders such
as muscular dystrophy or diagnose
diseases certain viruses which have rna
genomes such as
you guessed it covalent 19 hiv
htv etc
so next we're going to take a look at
the global market for pcr technology by
type
focusing in on the rt pcr market share
the market share has been around 13.7
percent
for the past few years and it was
expected to grow
on average at around 5.2 between the
forecast period which was 2016 through
2021. as you can imagine that number's
probably been blown out of the water
currently
but i haven't seen the updated numbers
but as you can imagine everyone is
really using
rt
pcr qpcr for the covet 19 pandemic
but previous to the pandemic why was
this technology expected to continue to
grow
well the increase of testing viral
pathogenic agents
had already started
um the technology also obviously gives
us the ability to convert rna into dna
which is very useful in the diagnosis of
infectious diseases ie cova 19
and the sensitivity the accuracy and the
reproducibility which was was
being processed and has been gained
severe importance in the past decade
just due to its capacity for making
complementary dna
one of the last things i'd just like to
review is really the difference between
extraction versus direct applications
so if we take a look at the application
area
nucleic acid amplification testing is
preferred over traditional culture
techniques due to higher sensitivity and
speed
is used very widely and applied market
testing to detect infectious diseases
and metagenomics and i'm sure you can
list out some of your own
what are some of the challenges and
opportunities associated with just doing
rna extraction
typically some of the
challenges in rna extraction include the
barrier to scale up the testing in the
molecular pathology lab
because of lengthy extraction steps
because of complex protocols because of
the number of reagents required because
of the cost the expertise needed with
hands-on
and then the compromise sensitivity with
some of the older methods
where
extraction-free methods come into play
and give you opportunities
we they can be used as a screening tool
in high-throughput and scale-up setup
where time to result is critical they
reduce the extraction kit bottlenecks
particularly
which have been particularly
prevalent
with the current night curve 19 pandemic
and they provide a simpler more
cost-effective protocol as well as
eliminate cross-contamination risks
during extraction setup
and what we can say is the nucleic acid
yield is usually not as variable as it
is with the extraction process
so if we take a look just an overall
high level viewpoint of traditional
extraction versus our direct rtq pcr
approaches
traditional extraction is still great
right it's the gold standard and
traditional method gives you high levels
of purity
you can use the aliquots later for
different tests save the rest
potential for
larger samples and gives you very high
levels of concentration however for the
direct chemistry if you're looking for a
quick t-a-t
or rapid turnaround time it gives you a
rapid protocol fewer steps less time
less hands-on time which means less
contamination potential
very cost-effective
convenient one vial containing all the
critical components for the license and
handle small samples with very good
sensitivity
thank you very much for listening to all
the background information giving us a
greater foothold on
understanding
the purpose for our rtq pcr chemistry
and our direct rt qpcr kits
so what is the cytiva direct rtq pcr kit
our kit can be split into really two
main components we have our aic mix
which is our anti-inhibitor complex mix
which really protects your rna that's
the secret sauce if you will
and then our master mix and
reconstitution buffers which is
basically our qpcr master mix dried down
into a life flies cake and then our
reconstitution buffer you combine both
of those and you get our direct rtq-pcr
kit which gives you the robust
extraction-free chemistry that has been
optimized for one-step
detection of rna really optimized
towards detection of covet
continuing in the vein of what is the
sativa direct rtq pcr kit
what we want you to really take heed to
is this kit allows a user to really lyse
the sample
basically by heat with the aic mix
stabilizing the rna against nucleases
and pcr inhibitors just an aliquot of
the lysate is needed
you can add it directly into your rtq
pcr master mix providing a highly
sensitive
specific amplification
and detection of rna from various sample
material and very in less time when i
say less time if we go over and look at
the
figure to the right you will see
if you're taking
from step one
of the gray boxes you collect your
sample then you go into rna extraction
you say rna extraction is approximately
60 minutes because that's really going
to depend on the kit it's going to
depend on the
skill of the person performing
using the kit and it's going to
really depend on you know a few other
factors how far things are apart in the
lab
if you come down to the direct rtpcr kit
you'll see that we
taking your collection of your sample
goes directly into your aic mix we say
approximately 10 minutes
but it's 5 to 10 minutes and what you
can see is the amount of time you save
from
the green box
and the gray box during the what we
would call the extraction free versus
the rna extraction
that's where you really get your time
savings you can imagine if you're doing
this extraction
10 times a week just look at the amount
of time you would save over the course
of the week
so i really want to hammer this home to
you very in a very feature benefit setup
so one of the features again
you lyse the sample by heat you put your
sample directly into the aic mix the asc
mix is a very
good stabilizer of the rna
you heat it for five minutes and then
you take an aliquot of that lysate and
directly into
the qrt master mix so it's a very
streamlined easy workflow
time and cost savings minimal handling
handling issues and minimal sample loss
our kit includes all the critical
reagents for
sample to result workflow there's a
stabilized master mix and they available
in cake or bead format which really
provides you a very
ease of use convenience very automatable
some of the benefits that we'll discuss
in the
in the data down below you will see that
with our
kit
you actually have a higher tolerance to
transport media
which allows
you to be more capable of detecting low
viral loads even when the sample
volume the sample transport media volume
reaches around 45 percent of the final
reaction volume
and you also get increased rna stability
of the sample
and we've been shown to detect cova-19
particles down to approximately 10
copies per reaction
so the benefit there is the kid is very
robust
sensitive and very reproducible
lastly
the flexibility of the kid it works with
a wide range of sample types suave cells
blood and body fluids compatible with
both real-time and endpoint rt pcr
compatible with the wide ranges of
transport media and suitable for manual
and automated protocols
really quickly before we got go into the
performance data i want to give some
background into our actual genomics
portfolio
it's very relevant with a wide variety
of different customer market space
future molecular diagnostic applications
fits in with qpcr ngs and other types of
nucleic acid testing
we have some great dna isolation kits
our sarah extractor cell free kit which
minimizes genomic dna
our sarah extracted genomic dna kit
which minimizes rna within your sample
our cellular extracted virus pathogen
kit
which has been used
very very well
with the covet 19 pandemic is really
designed for that
and then we have our extraction free
chemistry which fits right in here
we also have our amplification
chemistries if you have
particular amplification issues with
maybe a single cell with genomify if you
if you want to use templify which is for
circular dna genomifies for linear dna
and then we have some size selection and
pcr cleanup reagents what we call our
ceramic select
which really fits directly into your
workflow and gives you one option for a
one-beat option for pcr cleanup and size
selection if you want to know any
additional information about any of
these products please don't hesitate to
reach out to me
and now we will get into the performance
data
jumping directly into our rna detection
which is
exactly what
what we need to discuss right this these
are the the performance data that you
need to see
just a bit of the background we'll have
a bar plot and then we'll have a
standard curved plot on your right bar
plot on your left
in the bar plot you'll see the primer
set n1 targeting the engine of cover 19
based on
cdc suggestions obviously
the plot shows the results combined from
three independent experiments with
technical replicas run each time
the positive control primers are
targeting the human
rna p gene which i'm sure you're very
familiar with
we are also used a plasma template
control
which really is a plasmid coating for
the same artificial sequence contained
in the viral particles
and then we did an artificial viral
containing a portion of the cover 19
viral genome
in the last portion
and what you can see here is
we wanted you to see the difference in
the protective capabilities of our aic
mix versus no aic mix
you can see in the first bar the far
left
we ran
the samples without any asc mix for the
n1 primer set as well as the rnasp
you can see without any aic mix there
was no protection
so there were no results
basically as a failed experiment
simply put putting it with the aic mix
for both the n1 and the rnasp
you will see that the experiment passed
based on the ct value of around 35 or so
and rnap relatively low because it comes
up with basically anything if you've
used it before it's very very robust we
all know that and then again we tested
it with some artificial
um
primer sets as well plasma template
control
and the
artificial in one
virus and you can still see with the aic
mix we still get great results
we actually obtain results from just
five minutes sample right into the aic
mix
so the next thing i want you to take a
look is to your right
you'll see the standard curve really
demonstrating the linear and sensitive
detection of viral rna across a wide
range of viral loads
if you take a look at the
10
viral particles per reaction you'll see
the n1
will still detect it
around the same ct value
correct then you take a look at the 100
viral particle reactions it was detected
a thousand of course it was detected 10
000 and so forth
the
numbers on the right are not surprising
the numbers all the way to the left the
10 viral particles per reaction really
shows the sensitivity of our kit
why is this important you guys well
as with kovic 19 you may not have a ton
of virus on your system so if you're
able to detect down to very small amount
of copies
in the sample you can still
trigger a
a response that oh this person has covet
19. that's very very important
and then if you take a look at the rnsp
we just wanted to keep that in there to
let you know that
the rnsp worked fine in the experiment
so there's nothing screwy going on
the next discussion we're going to have
that i mentioned earlier is the
tolerance to transport medium
this particular case
we are using
nasopharyngeal samples from cover 19
negative donors and we spiked them with
a heat inactivated cover 19 viral
particles
so if you take a look here and this was
very surprising for us right this wasn't
something we
started out with the expectation
expectation that it was going to happen
but if you take a look the sativa direct
qpcr chemistry exhibits very high
tolerance to transport media compared to
some of the others on the market some of
the others on the market really tap out
at around 25 or 30 percent
of the transport media being in the
final reaction volume but what we can
say is that with our detection
we can get we can get up to 45 of the
final volume
of the transport media
and we still see
benefit we still see results
if you think about it this can be very
again very beneficial when testing
borderline negative or positive samples
you're essentially doubling the sample
volume test it without affecting the
assay sensitivity
so just going over to the bar graph
you'll see that we tested at 25
and we tested at 45 percent for n1 n2
and then rnasp
and you can see the results speak for
themselves there are basically the same
um so this is this is a really great
finding for us right and many of our
customers really appreciate it because
they can put in
again more of the transport volume which
increases the probability they actually
have more of the virus on board to run
through
to run their sample with
so the next experiment we wanted to
carry out with with the kit
was using different transport media
obviously with the amount of people
going into
trying to test coca-19 transport meteors
were pretty wide
wildly unavailable
the cdc actually put out a recommended
alternative collection media that can be
prepared very very locally
including pbs saline and then the more
widely used standard universal viral
transport media suitable for cell
culture
what we did is the graph to the left
shows you
that the sativa direct rt qpcr chemistry
allows the detection of viral load in a
wide dynamic range really irrespective
of the transport media it's used in
again we looked at pbs saline and then
just a
standard universal transport media
for cell culture growth
and using positive nasopharyngeal swabs
we were still able to see
the no template control there was
nothing there
and then the dilution factor of ten
thousand one thousand one hundred
one of the last experiments we did was
really just to show that this doesn't
just work with cover 19 which is where
the kit was really birthed out of but it
can be compatible with other viral
particles so we took a look at ebola
and
as similar as we did previously we did a
noise no aic mix with an aic mix and you
can see the results
that
even under challenging conditions really
defined by nasopharyngeal sample we
could detect ebola
viral particles
thank you for
listening to all the data i'm sure it
was very exciting and i hope you guys
really appreciate it last thing we're
going to do is take you through a quick
summary of the kit
kind of hit some frequently asked
questions and some of the top tips that
we have available currently
taking a look at this quick summary
slide what we're going to say is the
sativa direct rtq pcr kit enables a one
step extraction-free procedure using
nucleic acid amplification testing
technology
it addresses a few needs here right it
addresses the need for rapid and
high-throughput rna detection
provides a very sensitive and robust
reproducibility reproducible solution
with
highlighted
highlighted information such as
increased tolerance of up to 45 percent
of the universal transport media
increased rna stability within the
sample and again we specifically
developed this kid out of the need for
cover 19
and we can show pretty successfully that
we can detect cover 19 particles down to
approximately 10 copies per reaction
this
full kit includes all the critical
reagents really allowing kind of a
sample to
or
increasing the speed of sample to result
workflow
works with a dynamic range of sample
types swabs cells body fluids and it's
pretty easy to set up for manual or
animate automated protocols
so one of the things i wanted to take
you through as i mentioned is the
frequently asked questions about the kit
and hopefully we can clear up some of
those
for you
can the direct rtq-pcr kit be used with
any universal transport media the answer
is yes however we do have issues with
utms containing license reagents already
right if the aic mix is really helping
you lice based on heat we don't need to
like we don't need the sample already
lice so
any utms that contain license reagents
such as sds or guanidinium
should be out of the out of the picture
they don't work really well with aic mix
can i use other sample volumes
other than the ones recommended
we recommend five microliters of
universal transport media input volume
as a guide however based on the data
we've shown you previously the sample
can be further optimized with the
addition of the universal transport
media volumes being increased
being between three microliters and 8.5
is what we've been seeing kind of in our
labs
as long as you're keeping the aic makes
it a constant six that's this is what we
encourage
what sample volume should be used for
the rt qpcr mix we recommend a total of
11 microliters of lysate meaning the
five microliters of sample plus six
microliters of aic
to be added to the rtqpcr master mix to
get a final reaction volume of around 20
microliters
my starting sample is old and could be
degraded what can i do
due to the unstable nature of rna we
recommend working with fresh samples
where possible and store samples in utm
as recommended by the collection ii
manufacturer
can i use the aic mix to inactivate the
virus sativa has not validated the
efficacy of viral inactivation at aic
within the aic at 70 marker
70
degrees
incubation time for five minutes
lab optimizing to use our formulation
will need to do this
need to satisfy themselves
that they have sufficient approvals to
work with infectious agents using our
kids
can i scale up volumes recommended as is
difficult to pipette smaller volumes
we understand that however the accurate
pipetting of the smaller volumes is
recommended
to really mitigate issues when working
with samples with higher viscosity
the aic mix is not working properly what
should i do
it should be considered that the
efficacy of the
sativa aic mix always depends on
the sample matrix or
the type of swab solution
and the rt qpcr kit to which it was used
the top tips that we have seen with
customers
testing our kit using our kit using the
aic mix
we recommend using the
recommend mixing the axe mix before use
and then in the aspiration step as
intense as it tends to settle
if left to stand for long periods of
time five ten minutes fifteen minutes
post mixing
and on ice
when inhibition is observed with the
direct rtq pcr kit we recommend
adjusting
and or reducing the sample volume added
to the to the reaction
some rtq pcr master mixes are not robust
enough to handle the inhibitory agents
present in our
present in the lysate or present in the
aicmix plus sample
so if you are just using the aic mix
alone with your
in-house rtq pcr
and you're not really getting good
results where inhibition is suspected or
the reaction of efficiency is poor we
recommend comparing the sample with our
rtq pcr kit is obviously the aic mix has
been optimized
for covin and optimized for using with
our rtq pcr
kit
keep in mind the sativa direct rtq pcr
kit is not certified or ce ivd
marked but it can be validated by labs
looking for a rapid solution for routine
testing a viral sample so that
validation you can do the validation in
your lab and do your own develop ldt
sativa again has not validated the
efficacy of viral inter in it activation
with aic mix at 70 degrees incubation
for five minutes again labs optimizing
to use our formulation would need to
satisfy themselves that they have
sufficiently
approvals to work with infectious agents
create infectious agents using our kit
there is a risk of contamination due to
condensation on the pcr plate
we always recommend sealing after
opening for the addition of the pcr
reagent we recommend using uh just a
basically heat sealer which i know
everyone is familiar with
so just really wanted to do a quick
breakdown of the products and
specifications and kind of draw into
some important points here
the
if we take a look at the full direct rt
qpcr kit what you will have is the aic
mix with our qpcr
kit or chemistry
and we actually offer them separately
we've had customers that really wanted
to
just have a lavalized
ready master mix that they can
have in place or
have ready to go
to use with their with their in-house
reagents we've had customers that really
just want to convert their in-house
qpcr
to a one-step using the sativa aic mix
and we had success with both
so we offer the sativa aic mix
alone if you wanted to purchase it that
way we offer our
rtq pcr master mix and reconstitution
buffer separately as well
if you wanted to
really just get into a lavalized
rtq pcr
the
keep in mind the rtq pcr master mix does
not include any primers or probes but
all the other necessary ingredients are
that are required for amplification
to amplification of the target rna
during the detection step are in there
so really you just need to add your
primers and probes and you're good to go
back to the full kit itself the full
direct kit will con does contain the aic
mix as well as the sativa rtq pcr kit
and those are all broken down if you
have any further questions
please do not hesitate to email me or
give me a call
as we were winding down we i really
wanted to point out to some of the
products that have been supporting the
kova 19 efforts
and diagnostics using rt
pcr
just wanted to remind you saitif as a
whole we are
very into a variety of different aspects
of the lab sample preparation rna
isolation
whether you want to develop your own kit
whether you want to use kind of some of
ours i think i mentioned the sarah
extractor viral pathogen kit
above
if you want to make your own kit from
your
own magnetic bead
formulations we offer magnetic beads as
well carboxyl and silica beads
we also offer some oligo dt beads
we do poly a we offer plates
spin columns
we do offer
detection
detection consumables as well so if you
wanted some nucleotides you need to
attack polymerase or sci-die
and then back into sequencing we have
different things that you can use if you
wanted to
test out for size selection
or cleanup we have our sour mag select
we do have t4 dna ligase if you're
really developing in pair
and like adapter ligation steps or if
you're wanting to do some type of
enrichment we have ceramic streptavidin
beads then pcr again nucleotides we work
with kit developers we work with end
users we work with a wide range of
people
lastly i want to mention that we offer
most of our products
have the capability to be customized and
that's really where our strength lies so
we can customize many of our products
many of your in-house products so if you
wanted to make something lyell stable if
you wanted to
try out a particular formulation
if you wanted to do some type of
contract manufacturing if you wanted to
conjugate weird things on your weird
proteins on your beads or something that
you have thought of that would be worked
out great or would work out great please
don't hesitate to give us a call we can
help in all those
aspects
lastly thanks so much labroots for
allowing me to be here for lab week
thank you everyone who's taking the time
to listen to my presentation
again my name is donald green
if you want to have more information
please reach out to me
at donaldgreen
donald.green saitiva.com or you can
reach me at my telephone number
including in the presentation as well
i hope you have a great lab week and
enjoy thank you
thank you donald for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of the presentation and as a
reminder to the audience please submit
your questions via the q a box
donald our first question is can we
purchase the aic mix separately and just
use our master mix
yes that's an absolute
absolutely something that you can do
we've had plenty of customers do that as
well you can use our aic mix with any
standard
pcr master mix on the market
great thank you
awesome our second question is can we
test your lyo
ready master mix without the aic
again another good question absolutely
you can definitely test our master mix
if you want it
just because it's lyle stable easy to
use we can send you some of that to test
with your samples
getting some great questions in here
from the audience
our next question is does the protocol
take five minutes for all viruses
so we can't say that is a definitive yes
what we did was we optimized the
protocol for cova-19 so there may be
some optimization there that you need
for other viruses but for kova 19 for
ebola five minutes just worked just fine
okay great good to know
moving on to our next question
is the chemistry tolerant for all utms
all utms except the ones that contain
lysis reagents
we mentioned kind of earlier in the
presentation
great
another question that we just got in is
do you know if the aic mix works with
lamp
rpa or other isothermal chemistries
we we have not tested that
but if that's something that you want to
test we are willing to
give it a
awesome
and it looks like our last question here
donald is can sativa stabilize my master
mix
absolutely we do have the capabilities
of stabilizing your master mix again
it's just one of those things that you
put in a request for and we can help you
out
awesome
thank you for all your great insight
today donald and the fantastic
presentation unfortunately we're out of
time but don't worry any questions that
are submitted and not answered today by
our speaker will be addressed via email
or for the on demand period those will
also be addressed via email thank you
again donald and thank you to the
audience for your outstanding questions
this thank you everyone being available
yep thank you this presentation will be
available for on-demand viewing for 12
months
please remember to share it with
colleagues who might be interested in
today's topic and don't miss out on the
other presentations on our agenda visit
the agenda tab in the auditorium for a
full listing donald before we go wanted
to give you the last word um did you
want to say anything to the audience
um no i i think i've said everything
thank you for attending um i look
forward to your questions i look forward
to you reaching out
um
thanks
and thanks again donald and thank you to
the audience for your wonderful
participation and until next time
everyone have a great day